joining us on the line his vice
president Mike Pence vice president
pence thanks so much for taking the time
I know you're very busy these days ben
shapiro it is great to be back with you
i'm speaking to you from the white house
and just thank you thank you for your
strong conservative voice on the
airwaves and on the internet all across
this country well thank you so much so
let's talk about the the biggest thing
on a lot of republicans minds these days
the campaign
so obviously the campaign has an uphill
climb here I mean the polling data right
now so far is not great what does the
campaign plan to do to turn this thing
around it seems like you kept a lot of
ammunition in store it seems as though
the campaign really hasn't gotten
started thanks to a variety of factors
what do you think the campaign is going
to do to push forward in the coming
months well I think first and foremost
we're not going to pay any more
attention to the polls in this election
than we did in 2016
I just saw a poll come out this morning
that that had us down double digits and
a friend reminded me that the exact same
poll had the president down double
digits about this time in 2016 so look
elections are about choices I can't wait
to get out on the campaign trail I'll be
in Wisconsin tomorrow talking about
everything that we were able to
accomplish in the first three years of
this administration the president's
leadership through won this
extraordinary pandemic we continue to
move the nation forward we continue to
meet the needs of the American people of
families and making sure hospitalization
health care workers have the support
they need and we continue to see America
opening up you know we lost 22 million
jobs at the height of this pandemic but
given the foundation the strength of the
American economy the foundation this
president poured in the first three
years been we've already seen nearly 8
million jobs returned we're going to
continue to open up America open up
America schools even while we work every
single day to put this coronavirus in
the past it's that's the record we're
going to take to the American people and
that record of leadership and
accomplishment build on principles and
free-market principles growth will
contrast so dramatically with the the
more tab
there's more regulation big government
social liberal agenda that Joe Biden
Bernie Sanders aoc Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer are going to take to the
American people so I I'm confident about
November 3rd we're going to talk about
the record we're going to talk about the
contrast we're going to deliver a great
victory for the American people
vice-president Penn's one of the most
difficult things that the administration
has had to deal with literally since day
one and before day one has been the
media bias against the administration
the media obviously militating in favor
of a variety of causes none of which are
particularly good for the United States
on occasional just overtly ly after
president Trump gave what I thought was
an excellent speech at Mount Rushmore
they simply labeled it racist they
labeled to the defense of Confederate
monuments when he didn't make a single
reference to Confederate monuments and
that sort of been the theme of the media
throughout this campaign and frankly
throughout the last few years has been
the idea that everything the president
does is evil and and wrong it was all
about how the president wasn't providing
ventilators when he was and then once
the ventilators were provided that sort
of just went away it was all about how
the president was involved with Russia
and when that went away and they just
moved on to the next topic how do you
fight back against a narrative in the
media that is so overwhelming and
dominant and and how do you fight back
especially when they are fear-mongering
about Kovan 19 which is a very dangerous
virus but that doesn't mean that we can
all live in our basements from now until
the vaccine well I think we just
continue to tell the American people the
truth we tell the American people the
truth about what we accomplished in our
first three years I mean this president
I actually think been this president
kept more promises then he made to the
American people in 2016 I mean we
rebuild our military we renewed the
constitutional foundation under our
courts more than 200 conservatives
confirmed to our federal courts and on
the economy
this president cut taxes rolled back
regulation unleashed American energy
fought for free and fair and better
trade deals for the American people and
we saw 7 million jobs created and as I
said that that laid a foundation with
with even with this pandemic striking
our nation from China the president was
able again to marshal the resources not
just of the government but the whole of
America response where we saw American
ingenuity American biz
is stepping up we reinvented testing we
saw the creation of more than a hundred
thousand ventilators in a hundred days
no American who required a ventilator
was ever denied a ventilator hundreds of
millions of medical supplies we continue
to surge as we see outbreaks and
increase in cases along the Sunbelt and
then you saw the news this week I mean
with with the advent of new vaccines
that are moving through clinical trials
at a record pace you know I have to tell
you I have to tell you Ben when when
from from where I've sat in this process
despite the criticism not just over the
last three and a half years but over the
last four months from the media I say I
say only with this president and only in
America and I have every confidence as
we go forward we're going to continue to
take that case and I will I truly do
believe that there is greater enthusiasm
for the president and his agenda today
than there was at this time in the
election in 2016 so we're going to keep
dealing with this pandemic we're going
to make sure every state has everything
they need to provide for their citizens
that are impacted by the corona virus
the same level of health care you or I
would want for any member of our family
but we're going to keep opening up we're
going to open up our schools we're going
to keep telling the American people the
truth and you're gonna you're gonna see
this president and this team back in the
winner's circle on November 3rd vice
president pence you know the other
aspect of our politics that seems to be
so dominant over the last few months is
this extraordinarily radical vision of
the United States it's a place steeped
in racism and bigotry in which all of
our institutions have been thoroughly
corrupted from inceptions resulting in
everything up to and including tearing
down statues of Thomas Jefferson two
facing statues of George Washington I
think connected to two larger scale
rioting and looting the Democratic Party
seems completely feckless in the face of
this sort of behavior how do you and the
president plan to take the message on
the road that there really is a threat
to some of the fundamental ties that
bind us in the United States well man I
think as you said I think that's what
the Mount Rushmore speech was all about
and and to some extent the July 4th
speech from the south
onto the White House reiterated that
look this is a president that's going to
defend America where we from the
founding of this country we expressed a
set of ideals and every day in the long
history of this country we have marched
toward a more perfect union and the
American people I think can be proud of
the progress that we've made we can
celebrate that progress even while we
continue we continue to aspire to make
those ideals more real for more
Americans I mean look and with regard to
the canceled culture that we have in
this country that you're going to
continue to see the president and our
entire team stand up for the ideals of
this country and stand up for America
but with with regard to to the whole
issue of law and order in law
enforcement leaders I met yesterday with
the leaders of the top law enforcement
associations in America again and there
there is there's no excuse for what
happened to George Ford and justice will
be served but there's also no excuse for
the rioting and the looting and the
destruction of property in the intended
and violence against persons that
followed this and and yet we still see
everyone from Joe Biden on down talking
about defunding the police I mean did
Joe Biden in an interview just in the
last week was asked if he would if he
would support transferring funding out
of police departments and he said
absolutely yes and members a lot of
members that the mainstream media are
denying that he said that but it's what
he said and you know we're not going to
defund the police we're going to defend
the police
we know you know most of the men and
women who put on the uniform of law
enforcement every day are the best
people in this country they every single
day they strap on a sidearm and they
count our lives as more important than
their own and we also know that nobody
hates bad cops more than good cops so
we're going to continue to look for ways
to fund the police to improve public
safety but we're not going to defund the
police we're going to we're going to
back the blue
and and that's why I know the president
was so proud you received the
endorsement that he just received from
the major Police Association and I truly
do believe that whether it's the
economic record whether it's standing on
for all of our best constitutional
ideals the courts whether it's
rebuilding our military whether it's
standing for law and order and with law
enforcement that I believe the majority
of the American people are with us and
not with Joe Biden and the radical left
and we're going to carry that message
all across this country every day
between now and November 3 we're
speaking with Vice President penso vice
president pence and the president is
unparalleled when it comes to
characterizing his opposition it's one
of his specialties one of the best in
the history of American politics at
boxing in his opponents and certainly
labeling his opponents what is the
strategy with regard to Joe Biden
because it seems like there have been a
couple of tacks that have been tried one
is obviously that Joe Biden is not what
he used to be and then the second tack
is that Joe Biden is a lot more radical
than he is making it out I think that
frankly Biden is running a pretty smart
campaign by staying in the basement and
mouthing sort of platitudes that he
thinks appealed to a broad range of
Americans while sort of winking and
nodding at the radical left that makes
it kind of hard to characterize him how
does the president plan on going after
Joe Biden more specifically well we're
just going to talk about we're going to
talk about the record because look Joe
Biden is a liberal than in Washington DC
for 40 years but the Democratic Party
today has been overtaken by the radical
left and all you need to do is look at
the fact that here in the middle of a
pandemic at a time when American
businesses are starting to get back on
their feet people are going back to work
even as we continue to deal with with
the outbreaks across the the Sunbelt in
this country Joe Biden actually unveiled
a plan to raise taxes by four trillion
dollars raise taxes by nearly two
trillion dollars on American families
and but two trillion dollars on American
businesses and and I have to tell you
we're going to we're going to carry that
message everywhere because at the end of
the day they're focused on two things
right now
this administration and that is that is
saving lives and opening up America
again it's it's protecting the
vulnerable making sure our health care
workers have everything they need to
meet this moment and bringing our
country's economy back I mean with what
the president's understood from early on
is that it's not a choice between the
health of the American people in a
growing economy it's a choice between
health and health we we have to have a
growing economy we have to open up our
country again for the health and
well-being of every American and that
goes equally for our schools you know
the president and I I was in I was in
Louisiana just a couple of days ago
where we're working we're working with
leaders in every state in the country
working with the CDC to get our kids
back to school you know you're a parent
you know I'm a parent my kids are a
little bit older than yours but look we
we know that that the risk of serious
illness on the coronavirus to Americans
under the age of 18 is very low and with
the CDC's guidance we know that we can
safely bring people these young people
back to school back to our college and
university campuses and yet we're
continuing to see Democrats around the
country push back on that and we're
going to keep opening up so it's it's
about talking about a plan of the
radical left that Joe Biden is standing
on a platform he's standing on but also
don't make don't don't leave out four
trillion dollars in tax increases but a
little bit later today we're going to be
on the South Lawn talking about all the
regulations that this president and his
cut in the last three and a half years
that have unleashed the American economy
Joe Biden also announced his version of
the green New Deal literally two
trillion dollars in in green subsidies
and I don't think I have to remind you
or your listeners about the Solyndra
deal in the last administration five
hundred million dollars down the drain
in a bankrupt solar company now they
want to spend two trillion dollars and
bring back the whole regime of cap and
trade to crush American energy crush
American energy independence it is a
path
way toward economic downturn it would it
will wage war on economic recovery and
and that's the message we're going to
take beyond all the other issues having
to do with the culture having to do with
our ideals having to do with the the
right to life as strong military and law
enforcement we're going to talk about
our view for the economy that that work
before is working again and Joe Biden's
view that'll that'll that'll hold this
country back through higher taxes and
more regulation and Vice President
Penn's one other area where there's a
clear point of differentiation is
obviously with regard to China where Joe
Biden has a very long record of being
soft on China well what exactly is the
administration doing given the fact that
the Chinese have now essentially reduced
Hong Kong back into a state of tyranny
meanwhile there's video emerging today
of the Chinese literally forcing
Leaguers onto trains which obviously
brings up some rather nasty imagery from
the past number a million weigert who
are living in concentration camps at
this point what is the administration
doing to counter China these days no
president in my lifetime has been
tougher on the Chinese Communist Party
than President Donald Trump I mean when
we took office after eight years of the
obama-biden administration half of our
international trade deficit alone was
with China a country that had policies
like forced abortion and in the years
that followed we we saw the oppression
of the weaker population people
literally being marshaled into
concentration camps and then in recent
days we saw them break their work not
just to the UK but to the world about
Hong Kong they made they made a
commitment to for at least 50 years that
they would respect the the freedom the
democracy of the people of Hong Kong and
they unilaterally change that and that
that's why this president has taken
strong stands to impose tariffs on China
with those the vast majority those
tariffs even with a phase 1 deal we did
continue to be in effect because China
has not opened up their markets yet but
with regard to freedom of navigation you
know we have a we have a battle group
two aircraft carriers in the South China
Sea
in Secretary of State just reaffirmed
our nation's commitment the freedom of
navigation in the South China Sea we've
taken a strong stand for human rights
spoken out against the oppression of the
Muslim we Gers and as you saw earlier
this week the President signed an
executive order taking decisive action
changing the status of Hong Kong which
has been an economic asset for China
because they had a separate status from
China he's taking dramatic steps to hold
China accountable and will continue to
do that all of that said Ben I you know
this is a president that that that
believes in engagement in the world he
believes in dialogue we want a better
relationship with China we want better
for China but we're going to continue to
stand strong I'm going to stand strong
for basic human liberties and human
rights in China for freedom of
navigation and we're going to stand with
the people of Hong Kong well as
president pence really appreciate your
time and appreciate he's serving the
country the way that you do thanks so
much man it's great to be with you
thanks thanks for your Clarion voice on
the airwaves and all across this country
I look forward to talking to you soon
sounds great
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content